مرحبًا يا رفاق تشادويك ، أنت تعلم أنه
لا يوجد شيء أكثر إحباطًا من الذهاب إلى
متجر البقالة أو طلب الأفوكادو
عبر الإنترنت وهم
صعبون للغاية ، لدي حيلة لأوضح
لكم كيفية تحويلهم إلى شيء
دسم ولذيذ
في 10 دقائق.  معي في
المطبخ ، سأريكم كيف يتم تحضير
[موسيقى]
الأفوكادو المشوي مع الطماطم المهروسة بالتوابل
شيء كنت أستمتع به
منذ سنوات
والخطوات بسيطة حقًا ، كل ما
تفعله هو ربع
أربعة أفوكادو
ثم قم بإلقائها في  زيت الزيتون الذهبي
وتبليهم بالملح والقليل من
الفلفل ، ثم
نضعهم على الشواية لمدة
ست أو سبع دقائق تقريبًا حتى يصبحوا
جميلين ومدخنين ،
لذا فأنت تريد الحصول على الغوريلا.  قم بشوي
المقلاة بشكل لطيف وساخن على حرارة متوسطة
عالية ثم ضع الأفوكادو على
هذا النحو وشويها لمدة ست أو سبع
دقائق تقريبًا وستتحول إلى فقاعات وتحمر
على طول القشرة وأثناء
طهيها سنجعلها تتطابق مع
ماكين  إن صلصة السالسا الخاصة بك في المنزل هي حقًا
بسيطة للغاية خاصةً أثناء الخبز ،
فهي طازجة
سهلة ولذيذة بالنسبة لي ، الأمر كله يتعلق
بالمكونات وأضيف
هالابينو طازجًا أو شيبوتل
وأدوبو وهو عبارة عن هالابينو مدخن حقًا ،
سنضع كل ما في
المكونات
في الخلاط ، لدينا بصل أحمر كزبرة طازجة
خمسة أو ستة فصوص من
خل النبيذ الأحمر
والثوم المقشر الكامل وهالبينو متفحم ونخفقه
لمدة 15 ثانية تقريبًا ونحن على استعداد
لتناول الطعام ،
لذا حان الوقت الآن  ضع كل
هذا معًا ،
لدينا الأفوكادو المشوي وهريس الطماطم
الحار ، ولأننا نبتعد عن المجتمع ، فإننا
سنقدمها على أطباقنا الفردية
لإنهاء هذا ، يمكنك وضع الهريس
فوق الأفوكادو ، وإنهائه
برذاذ
من  زيت الزيتون وسكب بعض الحرارة الزائدة ، أنا
أحب اندفاعة كبيرة
من الصلصة الحارة هناك ، نذهب يا رفاق
، حان الوقت للغوص في من كان يعلم أنه يمكنك
فعل ذلك
مع الأفوكادو القاسي حقًا ، سأراكم
في المرة القادمة هنا في المطبخ
للحصول على هذه الوصفات المزيد من النصائح  و
حيل المطبخ الرائعة انتقل إلى
وصفات chadwickboydlifestyle.com